we all fell in love with the video of
shiloh dancing
bro i know
that girl is bad yeah it brings a tear
to the eye come on
yeah very beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i mean do you ever think like or do you
ever secrecy i don't want you guys to be
creative but when you see oh i love man
i love them to find their own way find
things they're interested in find their
own voice and flourish i'm obsessed i
used to take dance there and i'm like
she's something serious yeah i know she
i don't know where she got it from
because
come on
mr two left feet here oh here it goes
look guys
you knew this was gonna happen right oh
man i i think we're all just like so
happy to be out and about to get out
you know what i mean yeah people have to
see you now listen i'm celebrating 25
years in the business this year for
myself
i didn't think i had any more firsts
than me but talking to brad pitt about
fashion is a first you've been giving us
all the looks bro
you've been giving us all the looks
where what is it what is it in you
that's saying let me have a little fun
that's it man we're just gonna die so
let's like let's have some fun before
before we go out okay couple questions
to get into first of all i was told by
some sources meaning your castmates
that this cast has become a band you're
right right the name of the band is
decade below the line naked below the
line that's right we just wear shirts
and joey's going to be our front person
okay that's what i was going to say
joey's the front man a doo-wop in the
back oh all right so you don't play hey
okay
you don't play an instrument
or do you because i heard you're the
manager but you're still in the band oh
now they they
demoted me to manager those rotten
bastards and the first album is
apparently called no harness
oh that's right i forgot that boy you're
you're in the know listen i tell you
i've been doing my due diligence first
is that missouri journalism education
right
right the one that i didn't finish
by the way i would be remiss if i didn't
say because they've called me 50 million
times anyway you can tell brad pitt we
want to give him a degree anyway you can
tell brad pitt that they they want to
give you a degree right
like i've done okay i do but
you know the place place is pretty
special still what about bullet train
has made like because you do action we
see you do action but what about this
film
comedy action this is like one dave
leach and i the director we always talk
about jackie chan how much we love
jackie chan he's like you know
he's just our charlie chaplin he's he's
just so underrated and it's so amazing
stuff that he's pulled off so to do
something in that kind of vein with the
comedy infused into the fights i'd never
done before and it was really good fun
how have how has this been something
you've never done before as long as
you've been acting and doing the damage
as long as you yelled i didn't mean it
like that
welcome you never did comedy but i'm
serious like you're a movie star with
capital m s i say that well how how is
it that you hadn't done anything like
this i don't know it just hadn't crossed
my path or mine
and then you needed dave leech you know
dave leach our director he started as my
stunt double we met in 99 on fight club
he told me he's doing okay yes he is
he's doing okay for himself
[Music]
you